meu nome é joão mira alves muniz né
só a terceira filha de maria da
conceição alves de jesus e essa mulher
que me trouxe ao mundo com uma ideia
mesmo de me botar gente na vida é mesmo
com toda dificuldade a gente chegou a
crescer juntos em uma casa que na
verdade foi a rua é um período de dois
anos
eu fui dormir na rua o falta porque meu
pai nos abandonou nos deixou
e aí a gente vê um pouco na rua e
conheci uma mulher a mulher que era
fantástica né
ela tinha uma casa uma avenida de casa e
ela começou a nos trazer com a lavagem
da roupa da minha mãe ela começou a
trazer gente de volta pra esse mundo de
uma casa onde lá ela poderia até
continuar com uma lavadeira dela mas
estaria lá com a gente junto dentro de
um espaço fechado que não era rua e essa
mulher decidiu propor a gente né e aí a
gente disse que pagava o aluguel mas
pagava a partir do momento que fosse um
preço barato que dá pra gente sobreviver
lavando a roupa e pagando o aluguel e aí
foi pra lá pra casa desta senhora é
minha que era uma mulher que ao tempo
ficou com tuberculose ea gente cuidou
dela até o momento em que ela
desencarnou ea casa ficou pra gente até
hoje mesmo em guardam uma escrita dela
eu por exemplo fui vender na rua para
ajudar a ajudar a minha família a se
sustentar
comecei a pegar um carrinho de mão junto
com meu irmão que era jackson ea gente
começou a andar pela rua catar ferro e
um lugar que o encanto que era uma banca
de revista e nessa banca de revista o
cara ficava me olhando eu passar com o
carro de mão e perguntava assim incrível
né de olhar
a revista o tempo inteiro e não ter
dinheiro para comprar e aí ele começou a
juntar algumas revistas separava quando
eu passava ele entregava e eu não me
importava só com isso eu queria muito
mais queria lei queria ler porque eu não
tinha escola não ia para a escola não
estava na escola e aí eu pedi a ele para
ensinar e ele começou a me ensinar
eu acho que foi daí que eu comecei a ver
não foi à escola
lá é que quando eu entrei na escola eu
não conseguia aprender a ler na escola
mas ele me ensinou através daquelas
palavras barra do hisbolá 12 balãozinho
que aparecia e aí nesse momento eu fui
quando eu cheguei à escola eu descobri
que depois que eu comecei a 1 12 anos
estudar e descobri que meu nome não era
jones ii
não é porque meu pai tinha registrado é
como já mira e eu tenho uma irmã e uma
irmã que parece gêmeas nasceram no mesmo
dia que eu e ele foi registrar as duas
no mesmo dia
então meu nome era janice e o dele era
já mira ele trocou os nome à minha mãe
por não saber ler nem escrever
ela guardou o meu nome como se fosse já
mira e guardou resisto ea outra mulher
descobriu que afecte o nome ele tinha
mudado
e aí prosseguiu eu fui para a escola
pública aos 12 anos era 6 banca o
chamado de banca e aí eu comecei a
estudar
e aí quando eu comecei a ouvir meu nome
é dizer não mas não é o meu nome esse
não é o meu nome
e aí a mulher disse não e se seu nome já
mira alves monich e aí eu pedi pra olhar
foi para o registro e descobri que meu
nome realmente não era jones
e aí daí eu pedi para que as pessoas
pudessem me chamar pelo nome que tinha
me dado muita raiva tal naquela época
não é porque descobrir que seu pai
próprio enganou enganar sua mãe só
porque ela não sabia ler e aí comecei a
minha história dentro da comunidade
trabalhando com as meninas e os meninos
tudo o que acontecia de música de teatro
ele reclama de competição eu estava no
meio pra ajudar pra incentivar e aí
fazia com que cada um com operasse a
comunidade cooperava com que
tinha e os meninos também juntava todo
mundo com seus pouco dinheiro e fazer
compras prêmio ea gente começou a haver
a vivenciar isso eu me sentia assim uma
pessoa uma pessoa liderando aquela
juventude aquele aquelas crianças
aqueles jovens porque no momento eu me
sentia assim eu precisava de também de
uma liderança e minha mãe
na verdade ela conseguia dizer tudo pra
mim tudo ensinar até a entender a vida
mas ela nunca deu disse faça isso eu
sempre estava fazendo e aí acontece uma
coisa fantástica eu fui convidada uma
vez pra apresentar um trabalho de
cineclube e aí minha mãe não deixou e
foi quando eu dei o primeiro salto
eu pedi a orlando é que me levasse a
eles mas eu não posso levar hoje preciso
o conselho tutelar o conselho na época
era hoje a ajuizar de menor
ele precisa de fato é a autorização de
sua mãe
e aí eu disse a ele vamos inventar vamos
construir minha mãe não sabe assinar
você carimba o dedo a gente faz uma cara
de pau dele e aí ele descobriu um amigo
e conseguiu me levar me levar para são
paulo onde lá eu conheci muita gente e
depois eu fui para o rio é discutir
sobre cinema e ver a paixão pelo cinema
eu adoro cinema cinema pra mim ela tem
uma tela dá uma resposta muito imediata
o que a gente quer eo que a gente
precisa das vezes e aí eu comecei a
gostar de cinema
voltei com a idéia de construir o cinema
não era um cinema na rua mas é o cinema
em casa uma tela e um caminho reto
projetou a irlanda começou a juntar é eu
conheci o pessoal do de lado os
polivalentes san diego que foi a escola
que eu fui
quando eu estava no ginásio e aí eu fui
para o polivalente chegando lá eu
comecei a juntar com o grupo e formar
também um grupo de era chamada de grêmio
era um grêmio onde tinha essas pessoas
que hoje convive comigo que estão
convivendo até hoje comigo é ea gente
começou a postar esse grêmio com a idéia
de melhorar tudo pra gente porque
escola era nossa nem a comunidade era
nossa onde a gente morava precisava
melhorar
era nessa busca que nosso intuito e
adjunto era que a gente falava no mesma
língua todos nós falavam a mesma língua
querendo a melhora naquele bairro
e aí eu comecei a mexer com o cinema
depois veio o teatro o teatro foi muito
forte porque o teatro também me ensinou
a me libertar me dá um caminho não é
dessas coisas que eu vivi o tempo
inteiro sempre pulando pulando pulando
salvando se a mim mesmo eu só me salvava
e depois eu salvar os outros porque acho
que nada melhor do que você primeiro
pensar em você né
olhando pra você você pode mostrar pro
outro que ele é capaz também mas quando
você ponta a ponta outro como se ele
desce pra você a possibilidade de vida
você não consegue então sim tem que ser
a partir de mim e eu dizia isso desde
quando o primeiro momento que eu
descobri o meu nome então a partir de
mim eu posso transformar a vida das
pessoas
a partir de mim eu posso me transformar
e transformar a vida do outro e aí a
gente continuou fazendo um teatro e do
teatro eu conheci o quatro pessoas
também foram muito fantástico porque na
verdade seriam pessoas que diziam se
alisson branco não vão querer fazer nada
aqui eu não sei fazer uma uma baixinha e
depois sair daqui dizendo que ganhou
dinheiro do estado mas não eram pessoas
simplesmente pessoas que pensavam
pensava sobre a transformação de um
bairro tranqüilo pensava na
transformação da vida e eles vieram com
esse intuito de fazer uma transformação
na comunidade
apesar de um governo que a gente não
acreditava mas ele era o oposto disso
porque eles não era no governo ele
estava contratado para ser professora de
teatro e aí eles entram na escola
polivalente ea gente se junta e montou o
espetáculo um bairro chamado alagado
é o bairro chamado alargado também
mostrou muito quem era cada um de nós
como a gente via o que fazíamos e o que
a gente construiu nesse nesse espetáculo
a gente se sentia muito mais a
semelhante a ele do que a outro outro
grupo outro espetáculo que a gente vê o
mundo e nesse também nesse período a
gente tinha muito
coisa que a ocupação da ocupação que as
pessoas buscavam né
sua madeira para construir suas casas
para tirar da maré e aí eu entrei na
luta dessa construção de casas
engraçado eu briguei a vida inteira para
ter uma casa é e morava do outro lado e
no momento agora eu estou ajudando as
pessoas a fazer uma transformação na sua
própria vida que é a busca pela moradia
talvez me tocou por isso por eu ter
também ter dormido na rua e não teve
oportunidade nem demorar em cima de uma
ponte porque pra segurar em cima de uma
ponte tinha que ter coragem eu não tinha
coragem para morar em cima da ponte
morria de medo de mar
morro de medo até hoje não mudei morro
de medo até hoje
mas assim em respeito a isso a gente vai
construindo junto com a comunidade as
gestões da escola luiz a mãe me
construir um outro fator foi muito
fundamental para a minha vida foi
descobrir que eu era negra negra porque
a cultura não dizia a cultura nunca
disse isso pra gente que a cultura não
revela nem sexo nem co
ela só faz a gente vê botar pra fora o
que a gente sente e era a única forma
que a gente que eu consegui botar pra
fora tudo o que eu sentia
mas depois eu comecei a cair na real a
escola comunitária luiza mahin ela
trabalhava a questão do racismo é eo
racismo era uma algo que penetrava
dentro da gente e eu não percebia era
muito cômodo quando alguém chega no dia
5 é você e aí eu disse assim o senhor já
mira mas já mira de que é e quando eu
comecei a gestar a escola luiza mahin eu
senti na pele está dentro de um espaço
onde todo mundo que estava lá mesmo
negra estavam bem vestida e arrumada e
falavam diferente e eu falava do meu
jeito e lichia do meu jeito que eu
comecei a perceber que havia sim uma
relação de poder uma relação de classe e
uma relação de co né com as pessoas aí
eu fui discutir o filme próprio
apropriando disso aí dessa questão
racial de quem são esses meninos que
estão na escola quer que esses meninos
fazem da onde ele
vem eles vinham do mesmo lugar que eu
vim mas eles podiam conseguir ser feliz
eles podiam ser muito felizes e eles
podiam também descobrir que a
possibilidade na vida para todo mundo e
aí eu comecei também a contar uma
história a eles contêm no estado e disse
pra eles a gente precisa pensar na gente
e não no outro mas depois a gente pode
ajudar o outro
se a gente não sai o outro também não
sai porque é complicado você não você
sair sem o exemplo de cd tá fora
por isso que a gente revela alguns
negros algumas mulheres negras e homens
negros para as crianças porque é
importante que as crianças percebam isso
estão dentro dessa gestão eu consegui
contactar é comigo mesmo que eu podia
que eu podia ser capaz que eu podia
transformar a vida da minha vida vida de
qualquer um que tivesse o meu redon aí
eu já testei durante dez anos na escola
e fui fazendo dessa escola outros
pertencimentos que era as meninas que
eram os professora faziam comigo a
formação e peu espelhava isso nelas o
desejo de também chegar onde chegou
aonde qualquer um poderia chegar era uma
coordenação de uma escola que respeitava
e sabia da história dela e aí eu comecei
a pensar no teatro teatro trabalhar as
questões das dores que as meninas tinham
né daquelas dores que veio carregada
comigo que eu consegui convencer a mim
mesmo dentro do teatro e aí eu comecei a
fazer uma formação de teatro com as
professoras porque não adiantava ela se
apresenta ao país criança se ela não
descobriu delas mesmo o saber não era só
o saber que é importante mas que era o
que estava dentro de cada um de cada uma
delas de cada um de cada uma daquelas
crianças não adiantava elas chegarem na
sala em sinal abc está cheia de dores e
aí no teatro foi revelando as questões
difíceis de mulher de racismo dentro
dessas mulheres e elas conseguiram
romper uma das meninas que mais me
encanta até hoje que é sônia dias que
ela conseguiu não só romper com isso
como também hoje se chama transformadora
né transformadora de sonhos e aí ela
começou
ufa a sonhar que poderia ser capaz de de
coordenar um trabalho na escola e aí a
partir daí eu comecei a sair
e nessa saída eu já estava sendo
cogitada para fazer a gestão do espaço
cultural a gaza porque o espaço cultural
alagados é um lugar no meu lugar
há muito tempo mas esse lugar eu estava
sempre nos muros empurrando bater no e
gritando atrás pessoas que a cultura era
um instrumento de salvar aquela
juventude e agora estava eu a chamada
para fazer desse instrumento
lá fora a ser ouvido por muita gente e
aí eu topei
mas eu topei chamando a rede reprotagem
é porque a rede reprotagem é uma rede
que foi construído ao longo dos anos ela
não tenha tido tinha nome do meu passado
mas ela começou a ter nome
a partir do momento que os meninos
começaram a dar nome a ela que não era
só um grupo ela virou uma rede uma rede
de juventude e aí eu disse que só tomava
com eles ninguém acreditou que eu ia
levar todo mundo pra lá pra dentro
como todo muita gente ainda duvida que
eles estão lá agora por exemplo estão
segurando pra mim para eu estar aqui é
porque não adianta atacar os
funcionários não é só o funcionário que
funciona num espaço de cultura o que
funciona no espaço de cultura é de gente
inteligente que valorize o que é feito
pra ela pra ela mesmo e esse espaço é
feito pra todo mundo que teclar
então todo mundo é responsável por esse
espaço e aí eu comecei a vir fazer essa
gestão ea rede topou e a gente fez essa
gestão junto criando conflitos e ao
mesmo tempo criando amor né porque hoje
a gente percebe que a secretaria de
cultura ela tem uma linguagem que fala
perto da gente que fala de cidadania
e quem vai fazer essa cidadania não é
quem está no escritório é quem está na
vida quem está nos território junto com
o grupo e aí eu comecei também a fazer
me juntar com a valesca que é uma figura
fantástica também lá de plataforma
comecei a me juntar com o chico assis ea
gente montou uma estratégia política
nesse espaço de cultura e dentro de si
dessa gestão o que é mais interessante é
que salva vida gente isso salva vida
esses espaços
cultura nos espaços periféricos ele
salva vida
ele não é um efeito ele não é só cultura
por cultura a cultura ela é forte mas
ela é muito mais forte quando quem usa
dela pra salvar pra construir algo de
sua vida no contexto da sua vida e esses
meninos estão fazendo então assim já
passaram milhares né de meninos estão
vindo outros ea gente continua mantendo
né hoje já são seis anos de trabalho é
diferente é quando a gente fala de um
lugar que na rede lutar mas eu falo
desse lugar que eu estou esse lugar que
eu estou e que eu pretendo assim sair
pra outro lugar mas é um outro lugar que
tem o pertencimento muito grande também
de minha parte de uma história que é não
deixar mais morrer né tanta juventude
por causa das drogas
então é esse lugar que eu estou buscando
os né
um lugar que é de respeito não é de só
dizer que droga faz mal mas é fazer com
que o sonho o sonho desses jovens que
usam drogas que usam drogas um destino
porque usa a droga não é o problema o
problema não usar droga
o problema é que o uso da droga pra que
usa droga e com 11 com tem dinheiro pra
essa droga
como o jovem não tem dinheiro ele vive a
droga porque viveu uma droga é quem não
tem subsídio pra comprar droga e aí eu
tomei esse lugar agora descobrindo que
meu outro lugar
ser alfabetizado um sonho desses
usuários de droga que não tem dinheiro
mas que estava a droga
mas aquele que um dia a despertar que
pra citar a droga porque a gente usa
droga chocolate demais come demais
isso tudo é uma droga quando ela passe
em excesso quando ele descobrir é isso
eles vão perceber que não é droga que
está jogando eles na droga é uma falta
desse de se conhecer como ser humano de
se ver o que é possível é possível sabe
sobreviver é possível sair disso é
possível é possível distinguir sabe eu
do outro
e no dia que os meninos conseguir fazer
isso eu juro pra você mas este a droga
deve ser diferente
o mundo pra eles